open-source have kind of become the
default for software development and so
but do you see any any risk that you
know maybe companies will go back
because he saw the Redis lapse where
they change the license do you sometimes
feel that you know we might you know go
back to the item so from a development
angle I think people do realize how
powerful it is to just have like open
code and letting people be part of the
development process right so the only
situation where you end up I think going
back to old-fashioned proprietary model
ends up being for niche products where
were you you may have actually a hard
time finding that general population
that wants to help you so I don't think
those matter I I think if if you worry
about just open source in general you
should worry more about the whole when
you do everything on the web and that's
a service you can use that service with
open source and a regular Chrome browser
or something like that
but you're not seeing what's going on
behind the curtain and I think that's
that's what a lot of people are more
worried about and I with reason that
that you can you can get into this
situation where okay the software you
run on your machine may be open-source
but but then if you most of what you do
ends up being in a proprietary cloud
system anyway and open source everything
is part but at the same time we are also
building a surveillance machine there
people so do you I don't know how much
you know do you really care about just
the code has to be open source or you
also care about you know either the
business practices so me personally I
only care about the code mm-hmm I mean
when I say that maybe a lot of people
worry about the walled gardens and and
cloud providers and they all the
ownership of the data that you find with
the obvious Facebook's Global's apples
whatever that's not what I actually care
about it's not what I do I do code and
I'm just saying I understand that a lot
of people who care about open source
because of the whole traditional freedom
thing they will find it much I mean
whirring - how much is happening inside
the walled garden is a big companies and
I actually don't think it's so much the
code the code is is often open source
even in in a proprietary environment
what the big companies have is they have
all the data and that is obviously their
bread and butter and I it makes perfect
sense but but it's it's maybe a real
issue
you